the bridge over the rhone and the papal
palace our opinions trademarks the
historic city center is Walt inside
visitors feel as if they're in another
world Avignon rose to fame in the 14th
century when the Pope's residence was
moved here due to power struggles in
Rome along with the pontiff came a rapid
six-fold increase in population it took
just 18 years to build the main section
of the palace which is one of Europe's
largest Gothic structures to a guide
Philippe on figlio knows Avignon well
the sample villa the provincial
backwater town of Avignon in Provence
suddenly became the center of
Christendom arvin your was now a name on
the map of Europe and it would never be
the same again a total of nine Pope's
resided here over a period of about a
century high rank and clergy and kings
dined in the banquet hall ruling the
world as they reveled
outside the city thronged with people
who'd come to seek their fortunes today
it's tourism that gives avignon its
international Flair
almost everyone who visits takes a
snapshot of the famous bridge the Pont
d'Avignon one of the first stone bridges
in the region it was built in the 12th
century a time when the river was raging
today Telamon with us you come building
a bridge on this spot was really daring
people said that no human hand created
it a legend grew up which says that the
Angels helped a priest to build us
visitors who want to experience
Provencal cuisine should pay a visit to
oven yawns covered market
chef Julia shaw ave offers courses here
that let tourists in on the secrets of
creating that special taste he takes his
guests shopping in the market and cooks
with them this time it's a couple from
California the green vegetable is the
only vegetable which is intelligent
enough to absorb the salt it needs to
fix the profile the green part of coming
to France was to enjoy the food part of
the food is the local culture and what
they like to eat and do around here so
we found a chef Julian's class online
that it was a great idea and a little
something that we could take that home
from our trip
avignon is also famous for its theater
festival during which more than 1,000
companies perform actor guillaume l'as
saw works with a theater that's based in
Avignon year round the ambitious
repertoire has given the taya to do
Shinhwa a firm place in heaven yawns
cultural life for decades Papa kita
tunggu delightful do dim view a
booty-loving young is a city of theater
and it's like a theater itself when
you're inside the fortress walls you're
on stage outside you're off inside is
like a little stage you can get
everywhere quickly and always meet the
same people in the same place historic
Avignon is also making a name for itself
in the world of modern arts the
collection long bear is a premier
collection of contemporary works donated
by the French art dealer yvan labelle
in words of it Avignon is famous for its
summer theater festival which attracts
many people we want to hold exhibitions
and invite the superstars of the
international art scene to help bring
visitors here in the off season in the
fall and winter offices on Jimmy Avignon
a historic city that puts a modern spin
on things that's helped to make it one
of the most popular tourist destinations
in France
you